signori eccomi se non avessi fatto lo
youtuber prego bene tutti ragazzi per
lui di questo video sono parigi oggi
siamo su office astro ma mi chiedete
cosa vuol dire non ne ho la più pallida
idea però va bene ve la spiego in breve
ragazzi c'è questo lavoratore d'ufficio
che che lavora che la che lavora in sì
sì funziona molto bene l'ufficio va bene
questo è il mio capo che è tra l'altro e
non è questo quadro non è questo quadro
al mio capo
siamo alla twenty one inc che è il mio
posto di lavoro io posso muovermi solo a
destra ea sinistra
questo è il perché ho deciso di fare lo
youtuber permesso
salve ottima giornata di lavoro oggi
siamo tutti contenti di lavorare vedi
come sei felice
mamma mia ci sono i miei moduli state li
prendo il tesoro o eccolo qua ciao amici
tutto a posto
la smettete di baccagliare nella sala
d'attesa grazie per me io sono felice
meno ma non tantissimo quali sono i
tasti per usare le armi o ok ok allora
tisti segue della gente
non ho capito il perché ma come come
funziona devo arrivare in un certo punto
senza farmi scoprire dai miei colleghi a
io devo rubare di arca lacca michia anni
passati a giocare a metalli harper cosa
per questo veloce veloce oggi perfetto è
proprio a livello vabbè ma è bellissimo
ma sto male non aveva musica di ventagli
a tutta la vita qua sto a gli stack
agata nei movimenti metal gear zitti qua
è un problema io posso stordire i nemici
pure no perdo pro a prescindere perdo va
bene ma è cambiato è diventato pelato
adesso devo passare devo andare da dove
minchia devo andare scusami ma quindi io
posso andare solo avanti e indietro
adesso a sinistra orca vacca quello non
ha visto ok posso fare solo questi giri
strani va bene ma posso nascondermi da
qualche parte o è tutto così
ovviamente sono rubandole i compiti
delle vacanze oi progetti segreti della
apple non lo so però lo vecchio fenomeno
let's go veri ok ok veloce veloce
perfettissimo l'ex team race
vedi che non avrei mai avuto un futuro
da ho impiegato ma da ladro si eviti che
puoi distrarre le guardie coeli gli
impiegati puoi far esplodere la macchina
del caffè ora sì che sono felice c'è un
cestino
posso anche rovesciare il cestino ci
sono dei problemi in questo gioco di
fisica quantistica
allora io non sono un esperto ma non è
proprio reale questo gioco però vabbè
andiamo avanti benissimo snake sarebbe
fiero di te eh no a port che è che
pronto un nuovo fatto mi vede proprio
difficile sto gioco che io devo
nascondermi un cestino e passare non
esistono mai visto
lo mi ha visto non mi ha visto come
quanto può essere stupida uno che
entrava effettivamente uno che entra nel
cestino così potrebbe dare dei sospetti
è se non è proprio normalissimo l'udc
avevi cosa strani che a tiri di tutto
non so se è più difficile sto gioco qui
o se più difficile quello di venerdì 13
e dove le cavalcate mamma mia cosa ho
fatto un ninja c'era veramente il
medagliere cosa ecco adesso mi sa che
l'ho presa un po nel culo però l ho un
ricordo che la cina c'è tra un cestino
un cestino per la mia vita
arca l'h anno mi hanno vi servivano più
ok perfetto quindi se se
dopo un po smettono di seguirti a non
avevo capito io starò ma fatevi vedere
una per curiosità era questo lo faccio
per la scienza ma come perché non ha
senso ma va bene mi portate finire
questo gioco 7 su 8 cp sono le pagine
dello slider man
scusami let's go europei vi manca
l'ascensore che sta lì mini hub posso
correre subito dentro l'ascensore
fenomeno fenomeno se vogliamo mettere i
punti sulle i mi sono anche un po cagato
addosso prova per l'acquista che
distrarli in questo momento nel massimo
questo potrebbe essere un problema non è
un problema scherzava non ci sono
problemi per mister favi già in ninja
edition per fare in fretta sto gioco
conviene correre a volte brace non
correva pelo davanti barca ma devo
correre ma non ho capito quando se mi
fate la cortesia perché mi faccia tirare
da tutti e due possibile a uno viene di
collo distraggo prove l'altro l'altro
pure no dico questo livello è
difficilissimo porca vacca
se vi seguimi pure sopratutto tutti
tutti tutti casino totale vai vai vai
vai così o che in teoria adesso dovrei
riuscire a scappare in teoria far da lì
si stanno già stanno facendo quelli ecco
qua potrebbe essere un problema
i menù sono inquietantissimo c'è gente
ferma nella sala d'attesa che fissa un
punto orribile parco demonio riuscirò
mai a falsa parte si ok magagna un
casino adesso apriti sedano fai tutto
deiva pro veloce benissimo e mi segue
anche sopra le scale non sono pigri
questi impiegati attenzione mi fa
ripartire la check point però no dai
veramente ma [ __ ] facciamo messo
sei anni
correte correte correte correte correte
mario enna ok ci metto sempre una vita
ma vabbè ma potevo distrarlo questo a
distraiamo l'allora nuovo capito e no
perché se molto pisi let's go peraltro
cose che fa
la macchinetta del caffè esplode il
caffè come possibile
vai vai vai vai veloce st parte
veramente un casino permesso
eccolo qua ma mia garanzia sto gioco
mamma mia che rischio
let's go veri siamo tornati al menu va
bene come ma c'erano solo cinque livelli
ma no a cagà ma veramente magath è una
demo ma non è una demo sono cinque
livelli e basta sei scemo chi ha fatto
studio michele avete infatti l'avete
fatto in 26 se un gioco uno più pigro
dell'altro stefano lazzaroni thanks to
il peter pan
tutto il resto nessun interno è stato
maltrattato durante lo sviluppo di
questo gioco ma non avevo dubbi dei
ragazzi siccome è durata poco la
faccenda di prima primo fra i detersivi
killer faso l'ho detto anche a tempo con
il menu sono fiero di me stesso
poche volte son fiori mese su questa è
una di queste tappino tua maschera poi
togliere la maschera jason fai vedere
rimetti tela che è meglio ecco perché
facciamo un po di verità e da un secolo
non faccio sta sta roba di venerdì 13
quindi non mi ricordo mango come si
gioca però più o meno simile al gioco di
prima qui facciamolo prima di tutto la
guardia e successo a si è cagato addosso
quello logico che se per un livello sto
diventando così scemo non oso pensare
agli altri regalerà veramente ve lo dico
questo vuol dire al buio forse posso
ucciderli al buio possa uccidere gli va
bene ok che è facendo una strage rega e
macchine uno che non so come ma eccolo
che lo prendono prenderli let's go ove
vi manca il final che non so come
raggiungerlo perché insomma la studio
come diavolo raggiungo questo li
mortacci mia
facciamo una roba bella decente cambiamo
matto era troppo difficile per me questo
devono prendere un po più visi chi chi
chi mamma ma sì ma esattamente che paste
prendete in questo biciclub fatemi
capire se piccolo e martin garics a c'è
jason dietro bene con le alghe attaccate
e giustamente a ci sono questi muri
strani a che non ci sono dvd che non può
superare
ok proposto spaventare attraverso questi
morì va bene e quindi baisi la prima
raisi con un pesce chiaro
ovvio non guardano no a uno sgombro di
quelli giganteschi era va bene una trota
gigante vabbè killzone
mi scusi non credo che non fa niente
proviamoci dalla bellissima questa
uscito subito
ok la tipa qua la uccido con il
poliziotto aspetto che però un casinò a
dovevo tirarla via che pirla che casi si
prova veramente un casino let's go sesto
gioco sta diventando veramente difficile
regala rispetto a come era all'inizio ma
non è possibile un pesce direi basta
ragazzi per oggi va bene così sono
contentissimo sono soddisfatto proprio
la mia prestazione erano molto simili
due giochi però jason è sempre sceso
anche quando lui in persona ciccio gamer
pigna rieccomi servizio sono jazz
saranno j sentire che solidi spero che
vi sia piaciuto cosa non mi piace anche
ai social con iscrizione senza questi
scrive non ci vediamo un po seguito da
ragazzi
[Musica]